Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, which
is two one nine two.
David P you can call any time if you have
a message for me.
This caller admits to voting for Kirsten Cinema
previously and says she's ashamed for having
done it.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
This is Barb from Tucson, Arizona, and I am
ashamed to say I personally voted for Kristen
Cinema when she ran last time because she
represented herself as being a Democrat, which
she apparently is not.
She's just an attention getting brat stomping
her feet.
And I'll tell you this I have personally contacted
the county democratic headquarters and requested
that they start a recall petition.
We need to get rid of her.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, I appreciate the
caller for being honest and being honest about
her shame.
I actually I know Arizona has recalls for
legislators.
It has a mechanism.
I can't tell from looking at it at it whether
it only applies to state legislators or whether
it would apply to a representative in D.C.
like Kirsten Cinema.
I don't see it as likely.
And you know why cinema is still pretty popular
in Arizona.
I know there's a lot about.
She's just horrible and everybody hates her.
Federally, she's not very popular in Arizona.
Those are the folks who get to vote.
She's really not doing that poorly.
And so I don't know whether that recall would
work.
But there are lots of folks like this caller
who say I did vote for her, but I wouldn't
next time and we'll see what the future holds
for Kirsten Cinema.
We're going to talk on the bonus show today
about major decisions upcoming for the Supreme
Court, on guns, on abortion, on death penalty
as the approval of the death panel of the
Supreme.
Court rather is lower than it's been in decades.
We will also talk about Congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez is pouncing on Facebook and
saying break Facebook up in the wake of the
major outage that took place yesterday, which
affected Facebook, as well as Instagram and
WhatsApp, which we talked about at the top
of the show.
And we will talk about Lars Vilks, the Muhammad
cartoonist from 2007.
He has died in a car accident.
We will talk and review the entire Muhammad
cartoon story.
All of those stories.
On today's bonus show, get instant access
by signing up and join pack income.
We will see you back.